there's been a really significant gender
divide in the Hillary Clinton versus
Donald Trump presidential race in terms
of polling women have been much more
strongly supporting Hillary Clinton
whereas men and in particular white men
have been Donald Trump strongest group I
actually saw a graph yesterday where if
you went based only on men or even white
men I don't remember
basically Massachusetts was the only
state where Hillary Clinton was winning
among either men or white men and in
every other state Donald Trump was
winning among that group
however Donald Trump is very quickly
losing the male vote the numbers are
stunning there's an ABC Washington Post
poll which was taken just a few days ago
by languor Research Associates and it
shows that Hillary Clinton is now 12
points ahead of Donald Trump nationally
now there are some people who say oh
that that's not that's not a good poll
there's no way that Hillary Clinton is
actually up by 12 but let's let's step
back for a second from whether you
believe those national numbers the
interesting thing is how this latest
poll from ABC Washington Post compares
with the one from a month ago in terms
of the internals and specifically male
support of Donald Trump one month ago
this was before the Access Hollywood
Billy Bush grabbed him by the [ __ ]
video came out this is before a dozen
sexual assault allegations came out
against Donald Trump Trump was winning
over Hillary Clinton among men by 19
points that's a major major advantage
for Donald Trump it's common for
Republicans and national elections to
have the male vote one month later in
the recent poll the results flipped
where Hillary Clinton is now leading
Donald Trump
among men by 3 percentage points down 19
to +3 for Hillary Clinton among men in a
month that is a 22 point swing that
means roughly that in the last month one
out of five male Trump supporters
switched their support from Donald Trump
to Hillary Clinton
if your strongest demographic is men and
one in five of your male supporters
switch in a month to support the other
candidate you're in deep trouble and
that is exactly what Donald Trump seems
to be in there has been almost no
swimming swinging among women so the the
lead story for me that is not being
discussed much is that when you look at
Donald Trump's polling falling off a
cliff in the last four to six weeks and
Hillary Clinton's polling rising women
have basically stayed with Hillary
Clinton to roughly the same degree as
they as they were four to six weeks ago
there's been a one-point change in the
percentage of women supporting Hillary
Clinton men supporting Hillary Clinton
have increased drastically and when when
you look even further among white men
you also see a move from Donald Trump
over to Hillary Clinton absolutely
fascinating and it's hard to say whether
it was only the Access Hollywood thing
is hard to say if it was the disastrous
debate performances but as I've said
many times before if you are a woman or
know a woman or were born to a woman the
allegations and video and comments and
defenses from Donald Trump should really
turn you off Donald Trump's base is
abandoning him I have a graph from the
poll that I'll quickly show you which is
very very interesting
which shows that not only among those
who are white with no degree but also
those who are white with a college
degree they're all moving in the
direction of Hillary Clinton
increasingly there's been a swing among
non degree white voters towards Hillary
Clinton and that is also interesting
because Pat there's this idea that the
the low education voters are more likely
to support Trump and they are but
they've still been going in the
direction of Hillary Clinton over the
last month and just a touch on the
minority demographic back in 2012 when
the Republicans lost big Reince Priebus
and the GOP released an autopsy reports
they called it and it was their way of
trying to appeal to more minority voters
you have to do that but you first have
to lock down
your bass - you can't let all these
white men leave and go to the other side
no doubt about it and the Republican
Party has depended on my own white men
increasingly to win national elections
for a long time now demographically not
a good strategy last thing if you
believe all of these polls are just
flat-out wrong
you basically have to believe that that
respondents are lying to pollsters
because they're embarrassed to admit
that they're voting for Donald Trump if
that's the case that's a whole other set
of problems that that we're probably
going to have to deal with in a
different segment but Donald Trump
losing his male support really not
looking good